within the field of exoplanets because
there's different fields of astronomy
but within the field of exoparts I think
a good expectation is that most of the
telescope time that James WC have will
go towards atmospheric retrieval which
is uh sort of alluded to earlier you
know like detecting molecules in the
atmospheres not by signatures because as
I said it's really not designed to do
that it's pushing generous tea probably
too far to expect to do that but it
could detect for example a carbon
dioxide Rich atmosphere on trappist-1e
that's not a biased signature but you
could prove it's like a Venus in that
case or maybe like a Mars in that case
like both those have carbon dioxide Rich
atmospheres doesn't prove or disprove
the existence of life either way but it
is our first characterization of the
nature of those atmospheres maybe we can
even tell the pressure level and the
temperature of those atmospheres so
that's very exciting but um this we are
competing with that and that I I think
that science is completely mind-blowing
and fantastic we have a completely
different objective which is in our case
to try and look for the first evidence
of these small moons around these
planets
um potentially even moons which could be
habitable of course so I think it's a
very exciting goal but
um attack has to make a human judgment
essentially about which science are they
most excited by which one has the
highest promise of return the most
highest chance of return and so that's
hard because if you look at a planetary
atmosphere
well you know most time the plant has an
atmosphere already it and so there's
almost a guaranteed success that you're
going to learn something about the
Atmosphere by pointing jwst at it
whereas in our case there's a harder
cell we are looking for something that
we do not know for sure exists yet or
not and so we are pushing the telescope
to do something which is inherently more
risky yeah but the existence is shown
already gives a deep
a lesson about what's out there in the
universe but that means that other stars
have similar types of variety as we have
in our solar system they have an IO they
have a Europa and so on which means like
there's a lot of possibility
for Icy planets for water for plants
that enable for planets and moves that I
mean that that's super exciting because
that that means everywhere through our
galaxy and Beyond
there is just innumerable possibility
for weird creatures I agree life forms
you'd have to convince me I mean yeah
NASA has been on this quest for a long
time and it's sometimes called eater
Earth it's the frequency of Earth like
usually they say planets in the universe
how common are plants similar to our
Earth in terms of
um ultimately we'd like to know
everything about these plants in terms
of the amount of water they have how
much atmosphere they have but for now
it's kind of focused just on the size
and the distance from the Star
essentially how how often do you get
similar conditions to that
um that was Kepler's primary Mission and
it it really just kind of flirted with
the answer it didn't quite get to a
definitive answer but I always say look
if we're looking if that's our primary
goal to look for Earth-like
I would say worlds then moons has to be
a part of that because we know that um
Earth-like and from the capital data to
the preliminary Resort is the Earth-like
planets around sunlight stars is not an
inevitable outcome it seems to be
something like a one to ten percent
outcome so it's not particularly
inevitable that happens but we do often
see about half of awesome like stars
have either a mini Neptune a Neptune or
Jupiter in the hyperzone of Their Stars
that's a very very common occurrence
that we see yet we have no idea how
often they have moons around them which
could also be habitable and so there may
very well be if even one in five of them
has an Earth-like moon or even a Mars
like Moon around them then there would
be more habitable real estate in terms
of exomoons than exoplasts you can
essentially 2x 3x 5x maybe 10x the
number of habitable worlds out there in
the universe our current estimate for
like the Drake equation absolutely yeah
so this this is a one way to increase
the confidence
and increase the the value of that
parameter and just know where to look I
mean we we would like to know where
should we listen for techno signatures
where should we be looking for buyer
signatures
um and not only that but what role does
the does the moon have in terms of its
influence on the planet
um we talked about these directly image
telescopes earlier these missions that
want to take a photo to quote Carl Sagan
The Pale Blue Dart of our planet but the
pale blue dot of an exoplanet and that's
the dream to one day capture that but as
impressive as the resolution is that we
are planning and conspiring to design
for the future generation telescopes to
achieve that even those telescopes will
not have the capability of resolving the
Earth and the moon within that it'll be
a pale blue dot pixel but the moon's
gray grayness will be intermixed with
that pixel and so this is a big problem
because one of the ways that we are
claiming to look for life in the
universe is a chemical disequilibrium
so you see two molecules that just
shouldn't be there they normally react
with each other or even one molecule
that's just too reactive to be hanging
around the Atmosphere by itself so if
you had oxygen and methane hanging out
together those would normally react
fairly easily and so if you detected
those two molecules in your pale blue
dot Spectra you bet okay we have
evidence for life something's
metabolizing on this planet
um however the challenge here is what if
that moon was Titan Titan has a
methane-rich atmosphere and what if the
pale blue dot was in fact a plant devoid
of life but it had oxygen because of
water undergoing this photolysis
reaction splitting into oxygen hydrogen
separately so then you have all of the
Hallmarks of what we would claim to be
life but all along you were tricked it
was just a moon that was deceiving you
and so we are never going to we're never
going to I would claim really understand
the
or complete this quest of looking for
Life by signatures in the universe
unless we
have a deep knowledge of the prevalence
and role that moons have they may even
affect the habitability of the planets
themselves of course our own moon is
freakishly large by mass ratio it's the
largest moon in the solar system it's a
one percent Mass Moon if you look at
Jupiter's moons they're like 10 to the
power minus four much smaller and so I
wrote moon seems to stabilize the
obliquity of our planet it gives rise to
Tides especially early on when the moon
was close to those Tides would have
covered entire continents and those
those Rock pools that would have been
scattered across the entire Plateau may
have been the origin of Life on our
planet the moon forming impact may have
stripped a significant fractional
lithosphere of the earth which without
it plate tectonics may not have been
possible we'd heard a stagnant lid
because it was just too much lithosphere
stuck on the top of the of the planet
and so there are speculative reasons but
intriguing reasons as to why a large
Moon
Maybe
not just important but Central to the
question of having the conditions
necessary for life so moons can be
habitable in their own right but they
can also play significant influence on
the habitability of the planets they
orbit and further they will surely
interfere with our attempts to detect
life remotely from afar